[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue sur France 24 et
sur Radio France Internationale nous
sommes à New York et notre invité pour
une interview exclusive et le président
de la République démocratique du Congo
Félix Tshisekedi et avec moi pour cette
entretien Christophe Boisbouvier de RFI
monsieur le Président bonjour
monsieur
le Président ici à New York devant
l'assemblée générale vous avez prononcé
un discours dans lequel vous avez
dénoncé sans détour l'agression
militaire directe du Rwanda contre votre
pays vous avez aussi demandé à l'ONU
d'être plus transparente sur ce qu'elle
sait à ce propos pourquoi ce cri
d'alarme est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que vous êtes pas écouté
c'est plutôt un cri de vérité pas
d'alarme parce que les alarmes ont été
donnés à plusieurs reprises
pardon dans la région
à travers les ONG et autres
organisations
il fallait absolument
ce cri de vérité
pour que le monde entier sache ce qui se
passe réellement et qu'on arrête avec
cette hypocrisie cette cécité et qu'on
voit le problème dans son entièreté
et c'est ce que j'ai fait
alors ce mercredi à New York vous avez
accepté de rencontrer votre homologue
rwandais Paul Kagame en présence du
français Emmanuel Macron vous étirez
tissant apparemment mais vous l'avez
fait quand même
le principe d'un retrait des rebelles de
bounagana a été acté mais on se souvient
que la rencontre précédente avec Paul
Kagame c'était à Luanda le 6 juillet ça
n'avait donné aucun résultat est-ce que
cette fois-ci vous avez un calendrier
pour ce retrait
bon d'abord il faut que je précise par
rapport à l'initiative française
vous savez c'est elle c'est la France
qui préside le Conseil de sécurité en ce
moment et le président Macron avait
pris contact avec
les deux chefs d'État donc
avant la
l'assemblée générale pour qu'on prenne
rendez-vous ici à New York et qu'on
parle de ce sujet donc
de ce côté là il y avait aucune
objection de ma part et puisque je vous
ai dit que mon but ici était de venir
lancer un cri de vérité j'ai continué
sur cette même lancée dans dans cette
réunion que nous avons eu autour du
président Macron le but étant d'obtenir
dans un premier temps le cessez-le-feu
et le retrait inconditionnel de
bounagana
M23 mais ensuite de rentrer dans le
processus de paix tel que nous l'avons
décidé en aérobie c'est-à-dire avec la
fin mais fin total des violences à l'est
de mon pays et bon en termes de
calendrier il n'y a pas vraiment
calendrier
précis mais il dépendra du déploiement
de la force régionale qui est en train
d'arriver le burundiala le Kenya c'est
pour bientôt et la situation se
clarifiera à ce moment-là
alors évidemment la question qui se pose
aussi qui a été abordé lors de cette
réunion ce sont aussi les rebelles
autour rwandais du FDLR le Rwanda dit
depuis des années attention c'est un
danger pour nous c'est une menace pour
nous et en plus l'armée congolaise
laisse faire voire plus est-ce que vous
vous êtes engagé sur ce problème ou
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est une
fausse excuse du Rwanda
c'est une fausse excuse mais par rapport
à ces accusations je trouve que le
Rwanda est de mauvaise foi et que il
utilise souvent ce prétexte pour
justifier ces incursions en République
démocratique du Congo depuis que je suis
à la tête de mon pays
nous avons rapatriés à deux reprises des
centaines de combattants des FDLR c'est
quand même une preuve de bonne foi et
aujourd'hui les FDLR c'est une force
résiduelle qui ne menace plus la
sécurité du Rhône
elle ne menace plus la sécurité du
Rwanda en tout cas les FDR sont plus un
problème pour nous congolais que pour
les Rwandais j'en veux pour preuve
l'assassinat de l'ambassadeur
Italie d'Italie en République
démocratique du Congo au mois de janvier
de l'année dernière mais ce Luca
Athanasio qui avait été tué par des FDLR
qui sont devenus aujourd'hui des
coupeurs de route des bandits de grands
chemins et qui ne qui n'ont plus
d'idéologie politique visant à regagner
le pouvoir à Kigali donc c'est un faux
prétexte la vérité elle est ailleurs et
c'est ça que le Rwanda doit dire voilà
le Rwanda accuse aussi un certain nombre
d'hommes politiques congolais et
d'autorité locale de tolérer voire
d'encourager des attaques contre des
populations Tutsi congolaises quelle
mesure vous comptez prendre pour
empêcher que cela continue notamment sur
les réseaux sociaux et quelquefois dans
la rue les mesures sont déjà ont déjà
été prises déjà par la Constitution
notre Constitution est très claire
là-dessus elle condamne de manière
claire tout allusion à de la ségrégation
à de la xénophobie à du tribalisme ça
n'existe pas dans notre pays en théorie
en pratique lorsque c'est arrivé parce
que il y a eu quelques
dérapages dans ce sens à qui par exemple
nous avons immédiatement pris des
mesures et sanctionner les coupables
nous noterlerons nous ne tolérons jamais
de discours séparatiste
ségrégationniste xénophobe contre
quelques communautés que ce soit que ce
soit des communautés congolaises ou
étrangères vivant au Congo donc dans le
Congo que je dirige
c'est un fléau qui est appelé à être
éradiquée et quiconque va se faire le
chantre de ce genre de discours sera
puni et de manière très sévère donc de
ce côté-là je ne veux pas qu'il y ait
d'ambiguïté
je l'ai dit d'ailleurs du haut de la
tribune des Nations Unies le Congo n'est
pas et ne sera jamais un état
génocidaire alors pour contrer les
groupes armés qui sévissent dans l'Est
de la RDC vous l'avez abordé tout à
l'heure vous avez accepté avec l'accord
de la Communauté des États d'Afrique de
l'Est le déploiement d'une force
multinationale dans la région il n'y
aura pas le roi
il n'y aura pas le Rwanda mais il y a
d'autres pays vous avez mentionné
certains mais il y aura aussi par
exemple l'Ouganda et on sait que lorsque
l'Ouganda est rentré dans ces régions là
par le passé et elles ont laissé un
souvenir les troupes hollandaises
laisser un souvenir parfois sanglant
est-ce que vous ne craignez pas que la
population n'accepte pas cela oui c'est
possible mais il faut dire qu'en ce
moment
nous nous sommes dans des opérations
mutuelles avec les forces ou grandes
donc ça aurait été un petit peu
hypocrite de dire que l'Ouganda ne vient
pas alors que l'Ougandais déjà présent
en République démocratique du Congo et
lutte à nos côtés pour neutraliser les
ADF donc
l'Ouganda sera là dans une moindre
mesure par rapport au Kenya au Burundi
et à la Tanzanie par exemple mais
c'est parce que c'est c'était déjà une
réalité c'était un fait qu'on ne pouvait
pas nier alors quand est-ce que cette
force sera totalement déployée et
combien d'hommes seront sur votre sol
mais je vous ai dit que la force est en
train d'être déployée les Burundais sont
là déjà dans le Sud qui vous les Kenya
sont à mon avis c'est une question de
jours ils vont d'ailleurs pour votre
information entrée par bounagana donc ça
se déploie petit à petit en fonction des
moyens aussi c'est pour ça que nous
étions ici aussi et que nous avons pris
des contacts c'était pour sensibiliser
les bailleurs de fond afin de
d'accompagner cette cette force
régionale et donc si les Kenyans tombent
sur M23 à Bouna Ghana
voilà
vous savez ce qui va arriver au moins 23
depuis plusieurs mois dans l'Est du
Congo les casques bleus de la Monusco
sont violemment prises à partir par les
populations qui les accusent de ne pas
les protéger il y a eu des morts en
juillet
dimanche Antonio Guterres le scrutateur
général de l'ONU a reconnu sur nos
antennes que la Monusco était moins
armée que le M23
est-ce que vous demandez un retrait
accéléré de cette Monusco avant l'année
2024 bon d'abord permettez-moi de dire
que c'est vraiment
avec peine que
nous avons vécu ces événements
malheureux
qui que l'on voyait quand même venir
parce que depuis un certain temps donc
depuis l'agression
par le Rwanda à travers le M23 de la
République démocratique du Congo on
avait un discours
assez ambigu de la part de la Monusco
qui ne désignait pas l'agresseur qui
évitait de le dire et qui par moment
se disait même incapable alors que ses
sa mission d'être d'évoluer aux côtés
des forces armées congolaises se disait
incapable voir même refuser des fois de
d'épauler les forces armées congolaises
et donc tout cela je crois à concouru à
cette tension qui malheureusement
sûrement à cause d'ailleurs de quelques
manip à dégénéré il y a eu une
succession de maladresse qui a fait que
bon on est arrivé malheureusement c'est
à ces événements et cela doit nous faire
réfléchir justement sur la mission le
rôle de la mission au nusienne au Congo
et c'est à ça que j'avais invité le
secrétaire général lorsque je l'ai
rencontré ici ou Thérèse
à faire comme exercice nous devons
regarder le rôle que la Monusco doit
jouer parce qu'il lui reste très peu de
temps et pouvoir ainsi
partir faire partir la Monusco sur une
note beaucoup plus gai beaucoup plus
honorable que celle auquel nous avons
assisté en ce moment donc pas de départ
accéléré il y a pas encore de calendrier
de de départ comme tel mais je pense
bien que
de la monuscade devra partir avant le le
délai prévu c'est à dire 2024 à mon avis
au-delà des élections de décembre 2023
je crois qu'il y aura plus de raison que
la Monusco la Monusco resterait jusqu'à
la fin des élections et partir après à
mon avis mais il y a ça je mentirais si
je vous disais que c'est quelque chose
qui a été convenu il y a encore pas il y
a pas encore eu de discussion sur sur la
question mais je crois que de part et
d'autre on a compris qu'il faut
réfléchir très sérieusement la question
et d'ailleurs c'est peut-être ici
l'occasion de saluer les interventions
de du Premier ministre belge Alexander
de Crau et du président polonais qui ont
attiré l'attention de la communauté
internationale sur la question
congolaise et sur la nécessité de régler
le rôle de la mission
en République démocratique du Congo et
je crois que c'est c'est dans ce sens
qu'il faut aller alors on parle de la
Monusco on parle d'une force
d'intervention régionale évidemment ça
pose la question de votre armée mesure
le président parce que ça n'en souligne
que la faiblesse on sait qu'elle souffre
de sous-équipement on a parlé de
corruption de choses comme ça c'est
quand même un énorme problème et que
vous n'avez pas réussi à régler jusqu'à
maintenant oui bien sûr
tout simplement parce qu'on règle pas
une question comme celle-là
en quelques jours en quelques mois il
faut pas oublier que cette armée elle
est hétéroclite elle est composée de
plusieurs branches il y avait d'abord
les anciennes forces armées à Iroise
puis ensuite il y a eu les les fameux
cadeau Go qui sont arrivés avec la FDL
puis nous avons eu des rébellions qui se
sont conclus par des des discussions des
accords et ces accords ont mené à des
brassages des mixages et tout ça c'est
plusieurs corps en un seul corps et ça
fait que bon il y a des officiers qui
continuent à obéir
à leurs autorités anciennes etc donc
tout cela c'est à travailler il faut
purger
séparer le bon grain de livret et ainsi
de suite donc voilà c'est c'est un
travail de longue haleine mais qui a en
tout cas pour lequel j'ai beaucoup
d'espoir parce que là maintenant nous
avons la loi de programmation militaire
qui va nous conduire à mieux prendre en
charge les besoins de notre armée et
donc faire plus attention à son
fonctionnement savoir qui sont les
éléments qui peuvent continuer leur
carrière là dedans et qui
il faut extirper pour impulser une
nouvelle dynamique donc c'est un travail
de longue dans le résultat ne sera pas
immédiat voilà pourquoi nous devons pour
le moment recourir nous appuyer à des
forces amis qui peuvent nous accompagner
dans dans cet âge parce que dans cette
armée il y a de la bravoure il y a
vraiment des éléments qui qui méritent
l'hommage de la Nation et ils sont plus
nombreux que les brebis galeuses ça je
peux vous le dire les brebis galeuses
dites-vous en six mois vous avez mis à
l'écart deux hommes clés de votre
dispositif votre conseiller sécurité
François Bayat et tout récemment le
général le Philémon yave tous deux sont
soupçonnés d'intelligence avec l'ennemi
s'agit-il d'intelligence avec le Rwanda
c'est une autre histoire
d'ailleurs son procès n'est pas terminé
comme vous le savez parce que il a eu
des problèmes de santé il fallait qu'il
aille se faire soigner donc c'est nous
restons humains malgré
le
besoin de réprimer de faire dire la
justice et tandis que le général c'est
arrivé pendant
mon séjour ici à l'étranger j'ai cru
comprendre que il est accusé par
certains de ses collègues de les avoir
contacté au nom du Rwanda pour qu'il
puisse lever le pied et permettre au M23
de passer aisément et de prendre la
ville de Goma c'est ça que j'ai cru
comprendre mais bon
les enquêteurs sont à pied d'oeuvre pour
le moment j'en saurai plus quand je
serai rentré au pays donc on parle de
trahison là bien sûr mais François
Veillas c'est pas le Rwanda
à mon sens non son procès n'est pas
terminé je vous ai dit donc il faut
attendre la fin pour je veux repartir à
l'est du pays c'est ça vous dérange pas
l'état de siège il a été instauré en mai
si on regarde bien les résultats ne
semblent pas là en tout cas il se
prolonge pourquoi
qui est moins de violence que les
groupes armés sévissent moins ça fait
une vingtaine d'années qu'il y a de la
violence pourquoi est-ce que est-ce que
vous avez vous un baromètre comme ça sur
lequel vous savez mesurer quand est-ce
qu'il y a eu plus ou moins de violence
donc je crois pas ce que vous avez un
premier bilan à nous donner ben oui mais
je crois déjà que les groupes mafieux
ont été pour la plupart neutralisés je
crois que vous avez quand même appris
que les recettes de ces provinces ont
fait un bon en avant donc ça veut dire
que l'état de siège a eu au moins du bon
de ce côté-là celui de sensibiliser
les ressources et donc pour voir
maintenant les injecter dans des
programmes de prise en charge de ces
groupes armés afin de les désintéresser
de cette question parce qu'il y a aussi
le côté pauvreté chômage et tout ça qui
les avait amenés dans dans ces dans ces
activités il y a en étouri par exemple
plusieurs groupes armés
mon nom est unique qui se battait
justement pour des raisons de de
ethniques qui ont fait la paix et qui
sont prêts à complètement sortir de ses
activités donc il y a une lueur d'espoir
mais évidemment
je ne dis pas que tout est parfait ça ne
pouvait pas non plus l'être moi je me
faisais pas d'illusion on est dans une
zone où il y a eu une vingtaine d'années
de violence et de mafia et tout ce que
vous voulez c'est pas en un an qu'on
allait mettre fin à tous ces fléaux mais
et en plus et en plus il y a eu ça a été
interrompu par le M23 qui est arrivé
comme un cheveu dans la soupe pour
encore compliquer les choses
oui sûrement mais tout ça il faut le
démêler il faut il faut le comprendre
mais la détermination est là comme la
détermination jusqu'à quand l'état de
siège jusqu'à la présidentielle ce qui
est certain c'est que on allait déjà
faire un premier bilan je vous ai parlé
du M23 qui est venu comme un cheveu dans
la soupe interrompre tout on allait
avant
les vacances parlementaires qui viennent
de se terminer maintenant donc au mois
de juin on avait prévu une table ronde
avec les élus les la société civile
local pour voir ensemble et évaluer
vraiment de manière franche le la
situation de l'état de siège
malheureusement on a dû tout interrompre
pour faire face d'abord à cette
agression et je crois que si avec
bounaga ça se ça se résout on pourra
revenir sur ce débat là et voilà ça sera
président
tout à l'heure quand j'évoquais la
Monusco le départ de la Monusco je crois
que les élections seront en tout cas moi
j'en ai aucune raison je parle assainie
mais je rencontre
souvent quelquefois le président de la
CENI et parce que je veille à ce que
l'accompagnement de l'État soit là
surtout au niveau des finances et à
chaque rencontre que j'ai avec lui je le
pose toujours la même question que
j'appelle maintenant question
traditionnelle c'est à dire est-ce que
des élections seront organisées dans les
délais il m'a dit il y aura aucun
problème donc je n'ai pas de raison de
douter de lui c'est lui l'expert s'il le
dit jusqu'ici moi mon travail c'est
juste de veiller à ce que le ministre
des Finances fasse le sien aussi en
donnant les ressources nécessaires pour
faire avancer le processus oui mais tout
de même que ça devrait aller oui mais
tout de même monsieur le Président il y
a ce rapport du pneu de révéler par
africain intelligence qui dit que le
scénario d'un report et désormais
probable il y a le fait qu'il y a pas de
calendrier électoral encore pour
l'instant faites très attention à ce qui
a été publié là faites très attention
parce qu'il y a eu beaucoup de
manipulations j'ai vérifié auprès des
responsables du pneu de même ils n'ont
pas affirmé cela ils m'ont dit très
clairement qu'ils n'ont jamais émis
d'avis pessimiste jamais donc ça c'est
une récupération qui est sûrement
l'oeuvre de de nos opposants et
aujourd'hui
on sait comment on peut manipuler les
médias et tout ça donc voilà c'était le
but mais il y a pas de parce que il y a
des forces obscures en République
démocratique du Congo qui ne veulent pas
de ces élections
si vous voyez ce qui se passe par
exemple à l'ouest aujourd'hui qui
ressemble presque comme de gouttes d'eau
à
violence qu'on voit à l'est dans le
Dondaine ben voilà donc c'est clair mais
il y a pas de calendrier
viendra c'est pas le calendrier qui on
est à plus d'un an encore de des
élections c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas
le calendrier qui va qui va qui va faire
les élections c'est ce sont les
électeurs il faut les enrôler il faut
les voilà c'est ça qui est plus
important pour moi le calendrier on peut
le faire en dernier lieu en dernière
minute alors l'opposition
vous accuse d'avoir placé à la tête de
la commission électorale la CENI et à la
tête de la Cour constitutionnelle des
hommes à votre main et donc de vouloir
verrouiller le scrutin et être sûr
d'être réélu parce qu'on sait que vous
allez vous représenter je trouve que
c'est une insulte à l'intelligence de
ces deux grands hommes et je suis
le seul à le dire
le background de Nick à Dima par exemple
en termes
d'élection
n'est pas c'était le meilleur d'ailleurs
c'était il avait le meilleur profil de
tous les candidats présidents donc je
suis pas le seul à dire et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui cette question est vidée
parce que
même cette fameuse opposition
reconnaît en lui sa valeur et tous nos
partenaires ont aussi adoubé
l'individu donc il y a plus de raison de
douter de ça quand au président de la
Cour constitutionnelle il a été choisi
par ses pairs ce n'est pas moi donc
c'est un faux procès que l'on me fait en
m'accusant de d'avoir placé quelqu'un
d'abord c'était pas mon homme demain je
le connaissais pas avant qu'il soit
Président je connaissais pas du tout je
connaissais je l'ai connu juste au
moment où il a été nommé à la Cour
constitutionnelle donc avant ça je
n'avais jamais eu de contact avec lui ça
peut on peut le vérifier
votre bilan depuis trois ans et demi est
fortement critiquée par l'opposition
l'arrestation
il l'arrestation il y a quelques
semaines de votre ancien compagnon
UDPS le député Kaboul de suicide
beaucoup d'interrogations
alors vous êtes des interrogations sur
la raison il a été arrêté pour offens au
chef de l'État mais beaucoup
s'interrogent sur le fait qu'il soit en
prison pour pour ce délit et est-ce
qu'il ne faudrait pas qu'il soit
éventuellement placé en résidence
surveillée
ça c'est à la justice de voir c'est pas
je ne suis pas cette affaire
vous êtes donc candidat en 2023 mais
est-ce que des opposants des
personnalités comme Martin Fayulu qui
continue de revendiquer la victoire de
2018 comme Moïse Katumbi comme qui sait
un candidat procabila sans parler de
Matata ponio est-ce que est-ce que ces
gens-là ne risquent pas de vous mettre
en difficulté sur le thème il faut
sortir le sortant il faut un changement
c'est le peuple qui décidera pourquoi
est-ce que vous voulez que moi je mette
à spéculer sur
je suis pas Dieu le Père
je ne connais pas l'avenir moi je vis au
quotidien et j'écoute mes compatriotes
et essaie dans la mesure du possible de
répondre à leurs besoins alors
revendication le reste
appartient justement à ce peuple c'est
lui qui décidera le moment venu de qui
peut présider la confiance vous pensez
que je suis très confiant mais qu'est-ce
qui vous rend confiant justement face à
toutes ces critiques que vous essayez de
les réalisations nous en avons en fait
énormément regardez notre budget
regardez la gratuité de l'éducation
aujourd'hui nous sommes
à la gratuité de la santé les
infrastructures sont en train d'être
construites et il y a ce fabuleux et
ambitieux plein programme de
développement à la base c'est à dire de
développement des 145 territoires qui
fera date dans le pneu d'ailleurs
a dit que c'était le plus beau programme
de de toute l'existence du pneu on n'a
jamais vu ça et il permettra à la
République démocratique du Congo
d'atteindre 12 de 17 au DD donc c'est
pour vous dire que nous travaillons pour
notre peuple nous sommes au service de
notre peuple évidemment ce pays
il revient de loin je ne monsieur bois
Bouvier c'est pas à vous que je vais
décrire l'image que la République
démocratique du Congo avait dans le
concert des nations ne fut-ce que pour
entendre la voix de la République
démocratique du Congo c'était
impossible
le pays était devenu un faune à une
époque et nous avons réussi à ramener le
pays à l'agenda
international aujourd'hui on parle de la
RDC on parle de nous comme pays
solutions au niveau environnemental on
parle de nous comme
pays d'avenir parce que nous avons une
jeunesse
formidable ingénieuse qui est prête qui
est très dynamique prête à servir il
faut il faut simplement encadrer tout
cela et c'est à cela que nous nous
appelons et nous sommes convaincus que
les choses le moment venu vont être
appréciés par nos compatriotes et il
nous renouvelerons renouvelerons leur
confiance donc il y a vraiment pas de
pas d'inquiétude de ce côté là
excusez-moi j'ai juste une c'est pour ça
que l'opposition a peur d'aller aux
élections d'ailleurs j'ai juste une
petite question sur quelque chose que
vous avez dit qui m'a intrigué vous avez
parlé d'une main noire oui bien sûr mais
vous parlez quoi de possible coup d'État
de déstabilisation
étrangères ou oui et non on est en train
d'élucider la question les arrestations
que vous voyez là dont on a parlé dans
l'armée ne sont pas le fait du hasard
il y a réellement une main noire posait
la question à notre gouverneur la
nouvelle gouverneur de main Doumbé qui
suit la question de cette insécurité de
très près que j'ai reçu juste avant de
venir elle en parle le gouverneur du
Congo aussi donc
ils en parlent
parce que de ce côté là on a jamais vu
ce genre de fait c'est vrai que les
cohabitations entre communautés ont de
tout temps poser des problèmes même dans
les pays à tradition démocratique c'est
arrivé mais cette manifestation de
violence telle qu'on la voit et qui
ressemble comme je disais à ce qu'on
voit à l'est avec des décapitations avec
des choses comme ça
c'est du jamais vu c'est ça veut dire
que il y a quelque chose qui se trame et
il y a eu des arrestations on a par
exemple arrêté des gens qui ne parlent
aucune des langues nationales ni de
dialecte du pays et qui parle une langue
étrangère
les enquêtes nous le diront le moment
venu et d'où l'arrestation de François
Bayern ah non non ça c'est
François Bayard c'est arrivé avant ça
n'a rien à voir avec d'où l'arrestation
peut-être
du général
on fera en tout cas on verra quel lien
ça avec
avec ces événements là merci monsieur le
Président de nous avoir accordé cet
entretien c'est moi c'est moi qui vous
remercie et merci à vous de nous avoir
suivi sur nos deux chaînes France 24 et
Radio France Internationale
[Musique]